by adjusting flow and pressure in the
pulmonary artery allows them to heal
themselves this is old technology that's
been around since the 50s but it was
done in a much much different way it was
done by some pulmonary artery banding
which is an open chest procedure we came
up with a minimally evasive procedure
which goes beyond what pulmonary artery
banding is supposed to be because our
our product is adjustable
any time after the initial insertions
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret chord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
death Bogner welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you for joining me for a
fun conversation how are you great
Michael thanks for having me
thank you very much for for joining me
and you're the chairman and CEO of
hardpoint global and soon we'll talk
about how you how how what you're doing
in the healthcare field and the cardiac
field to make it a a meaningful impact
on a lot of people's lives literally and
then and what's just as interesting as
what you're doing with hardpoint global
is the journey that got you to hardpoint
Global and to what you're doing today
and so I'm excited to sort of unravel
this with you over these 20 minutes and
tell your story so again thank you very
much for being here
wonderful well tell me a little bit
about you know what what do you care
about yeah let's start there and then
we'll go back to your journey well
um
you know I I what do I care about you
know it's
I really focused in my business and my
personal life on trying to make the
world a better place and I spent most of
my career which goes back hold up over
three decades of
um creating things of the financial
services business and and I thought was
important to sort of evolve what we're
doing and it's not just me evolving it's
it's her capitalism evolving and just to
receive for profit alone is great
there's nothing matter with that it
served us for a long time but I think
now you know especially
at times we live in what we've seen with
covet where we've seen with the last
financial crisis what we're seeing in
this financial crisis is everything in
the world's interconnected everything in
the world is uh is is is is a part of
one thing and I think if you do a little
good and make money at the same time you
know we will we're not Communists
um you know we could incorporate that
into your thinking it's your intention
that allows you as an investor to work
or is it whereas somebody who runs a
business or a matchup Works
um I think really good things come out
of it I think all of our employees well
I know all of our employees uh and a lot
of good glitter attached to our business
came because of our social Mission as
much as for the economics of the of the
business
so I think if everyone try to
incorporate that just a little bit you
know they don't have to be like us and
you know have two separate business
plans one for the developing world and
one fork the developed world but but
just to incorporate just a little bit of
that business I think it makes the world
a better place and I think it makes all
of us as people better people and it
improves the general vibration of the
world
that's awesome how did you
um get here I mean was there a I mean
you started you said you were in the
financial what led to sort of you now
um spending a significant amount of time
you know talking this way and thinking
this way
um
well I made the investment in a company
and I don't think anything's by accident
I think it was fatalistic that that that
that I was I I was presented at this
company
that
had a new way to ensure a lot of in a
lot of cardiac indications and a new
simpler way that would make it much more
accessible from people around the world
of uh and what happened was is the pupil
and in spite of the great doctors and
founders of everyone else who you know
started the company they were really
good at at
conceptualizing planes but they were
really good at doing fudge and I brought
to bear you know all my experience and
company formation restructuring
desperate management and kept calling
with the bird deeper and then when we
were about when a free four years into
the investment I said that it really
just wasn't working and it needed me to
really that didn't have to be me it
could have been somebody else with the
same sort of skill set to come into the
business to really focus
um on creating the business structures
that are necessary to have a successful
business you know we're not a startup
we're advanced than that but I don't
know um you know
the company at that point was based in
Switzerland at a production agreement
with a company in Germany we lose the
company to Ireland and subsequently
moved most of our operations or at least
r d to Israel and uh you know we you
know have this culture this energy about
not just doing something good but also
helping in the world and we've had a lot
to overcome on um you know we've had
covet we've had supply chain shortage
we've had we're doing all planning on
doing all of our uh our clinical testing
in Ukraine uh so we just got banged in
every possible way you can and you know
and up to this coin I've supported I've
supported the company and the investment
in company uh Leo passed a journey for
to me personally and that has allowed us
to go through obviously we're looking
for you know the right partners
and you know to each of the couple of
forward and you know companies that
aspirely public companies or uh I think
it was before we would get to that level
are Symphonies not solo hacks so we are
customer searching for more and more
people to have involved in malware good
and uh we're a pretty exciting stage uh
right there
okay what when you made that decision to
to join officially as I guess chairman
and CEO this who started as an investor
and you joined as and then you
transitioned to very be taking a very
active role that's a a pretty big life
decision Beyond a financial one so talk
to me a little bit about you know that
it's not a trivial decision
well you know I think everybody has a
few careers in the you know uh example
you served in in the Army and then you
we started the business
um You probably be successful at that
and start another business uh that will
probably be different to the first
business you start I've started a lot of
businesses and I've done a lot of firsts
and I for the better Force I get forward
to eat feasible and and uh and I also am
somebody who does a lot of research and
then on my own and in a little bit so
unless I really understood
um
possibilities of what we're doing at car
point
I
yeah there's
the correct word
there was an
opportunity that had really needed
somebody to step forward because it was
going to help people all over the world
and not only that it's gonna make a lot
of money so
um
that decision
um I was living between Israel and Italy
most of the time then I'm now spending
more time in New York
and that decision was sort of an easy
one I sat down with my wife and I said
listen we want to do something that's
really going to help the world and uh
she was she was she was on board but you
know and I I gradually reduced my
responsibilities in my other Enterprise
so that allowed me to focus on this you
know full-time
yes well to me a little bit about the
um the the products that you're working
on what is the technology behind it why
why does it matter to the world yeah
obviously it matters when a seventh year
in neural Wars yeah we have
um the ability to
well first of all it's a it's it's a
system that that works in a hard lung
system and it allows
um patience to
the in essence crew right by adjusting
flow of pressure in the pulmonary artery
allows them to heal themselves
um this is old technology that's been
around since the 50s but it was done in
a much much different way it was done by
um
pulmonary artery banding which is an
open chest procedure we came up with a
minimally evasive procedure which goes
beyond what pulmonary artery banding is
supposed to be because our our product
is adjustable
any time after the initial insertion so
right on the spot if we didn't get the
adjustment price a year or day if
patient is a child then grows you know
you've always changed the pressure on
Flow and that is for
left heart disease primarily in the
developed world meaning very sick people
who have you know cardiovascular disease
is the biggest killer in the world the
largest subsection of cardiovascular
disease are left is left heart disease
and the largest subsection of that of
left heart disease something called
cardiomyopathy and we can help many many
types of cardiomyop with the patients
and at the same time in the developing
world we have a one in a hundred kids is
born with an ASD or VST so A congenital
crazy fact that's a huge huge number and
we could help a lot of those kids
um and and once again it's by you know
these kids healing themselves plus you
know our technology is useful for people
not just in the cardiovascular system
but if you have somebody who has stress
the liver and their work what we call a
tips patient
um they have the same need of the
adjustable technology that we hold
patent Assad
to uh to adjust flow and pressure that
could help treat uh cirrhosis so you
know it's it's in what's what's
interesting about us is we're not a heck
kind of Technology it's actually
you know welcome's razor types of thing
that the simplest solution is generally
the best solution so the path that we
old is basically when extents which are
normally used for either opening up an
artery or plugging up an art or you know
a hole in an artery produced
therapeutically
um by nesting inside each hour
uh this is a simple simple
simple solution that allows us to do
things in different parts of the body
add
you know going into the pulmonary artery
is a big deal and we've done tons of
pre-clinical work in Israel
um and the half uh uh which is near best
show
and uh you know we it took a lot of work
to be to do this in a safe and effective
way so now where koi is about to go into
the Reds on Old Man's you know their
care of care
you know right but if you take the
extreme example each in the western
world if somebody needs or in the United
States if somebody needs an artificial
part of lvod over 10 years and it's
great that they can live 10 years with
an ldad nowadays
who cost a million dollars
um our device costs uh four thousand
dollars and even in with Hospital costs
being what they are in the United States
you know so let's say it's 25 30 000
because it is it it you're going to keep
somebody overnight uh but it's it's you
know they're they're in and out people
see how ripping open their their their
their their their chest
so
we are you know really very very rapidly
towards speak able cheat with a tree
should treat full and super respect
makes others out we have a little low
ping buried with Hauser first ever our
first to pay them so and it's a long
long road to get that you know yeah
what is a go to market in something like
this look like uh how do you think about
that through the worst of it you know
which was all the r d
and you know we've done all the all the
pre-clinical work that is necessary but
now we go through the approval process
and we go through the approval process
in the FDA in the United States uh you
know CE and also
um there are a lot of other Health Care
Systems especially since we're doing so
much workloop development world that are
not part of you know the FDA new or CB I
think you know where symptoms approved
did by the FDA and could use it in
Israel uh but and it's like that a lot
of cultures so you know at least we'll
have another another yeah three years of
going Market that in to bring you up
highly regulated areas in area we've
been focused in crane
um all of the a you know we're dealing
with
but the quick go to work with the CIS
countries we have formed Soviet
attrition
uh and we have several other you know
quickly go to work it's like they're
there are so many places where they need
well we have art
um
are are achievable markets 34 million
patients right now throughout the world
so you know you can go to a country like
Nigeria you know like 200 million people
and stay very busy there assuming people
or get the approvals in that one country
while you're going for your FDA unseen
eight year you approval
so uh you know we have a two-prongo to
Market strategy what could the developed
world of Montana
and what is that like for you
being involved in something that you
know takes years of r d
regulatory approval processes you know
how do you what's what is that
experience like for you as as an
executive and for people as their daily
work until you get to see the fruits of
it live on the field you know with
people reacting to it well you know
we're we're lucky
um first of all we have such a great
team of skilled professionals uh you
know like our regular our regulatory guy
uh but is is the is it was a regulatory
guy in Ireland and the Irish
representative towards the new
regulations they have in Europe uh so we
deal with regulatory as a regulator
looks at it uh
and it I'm sorry what was the second
part of your question
so spending that time to
to
um
both you as an executive and the people
working with you on this
no not saying necessarily the product
you know in the hands of customers and
getting that feedback coming from a
software background right well also you
know we've done so many pre-clinical
studies we've seen the evolution of of
of of so it's sort of through this so
you're saying through the the
pre-clinical studies and and through the
process here you are saying you are
feeling the product getting tested and
getting feedback absolutely absolutely
like you know uh three weeks ago we did
what I what I call our dress rehearsal
for firstly Newman and uh we had
unbelievable results you know that
that's that surpassed our expectations
uh that also is part of you know the
strict uh testing process that we have
to go through building a class three
medical device simplest support
so uh no I'm very very uh you know we
it's not hard keeping motivated
um what was hard was when you put so
much work into Ukraine and you see you
can't get evaded in the whole
unfortunate situation was hard it is as
as some you know knowing that we could
be helping people and having to slow
down because of covet no way or
according you know trying to Source uh
PTFE which is artificial in
a psycho who am not a base product that
we need for inside of our chest and
though that there's a global shortage of
PTF and I love that when you find it
it's four types what you thought it cost
you know these are the frustrations
we've had to deal with but you know
because of such great team
um who are experienced and
you know I just gave you one example
with a realtor guy but you know our CTO
you know and was supposed was chief
engineer for you know another part
related uh company in Israel that you
know to genes it for over 600 million
dollars so you know people in our team
for doctors all have been involved in
other things that have been successful
so it's it's it's me and if people have
meet if
this process work and I am worried about
the exit so much and you know I know in
Israel you know everyone's like well
what's the exit what's the exit you know
I think if you run a good company and
you and you we're trying to do good
things uh for your shareholders and for
the world the exit becomes natural uh
and doesn't have to be an exit could go
public and uh with the word stay private
and make lots of money for people if
you're a cash flow oriented company like
we are so well we are already being out
with this there's nothing to matter with
cash it's not all about exit uh never
been you know not as sensitive as most
people are to valuation
because I think it should do and
continue to do the right thing you can
uh generate a lot of money evaluation
doesn't mean as much to me as it would
necessarily to others and I'm going
through this process now as was talking
to investors you know about coming into
the company
I'm looking more for the right kind of
investor than I am about you know
looking for the one who's going to give
me the best valuation because you know
as I think I said earlier in a public
companies or companies to get mature
except Vinnies and uh you know I know
that the right types of parameter is
we're a type of burger it's just you
know what type of money bring it to a
company is just as important as a matter
by poo perfect
I love it Seth I really appreciate your
time and your work and the way the
insights that you've shared a little bit
from your own personal experience and
and all obviously the why you're doing
what you're doing so I I wishing you
best of luck with hardpoint global and
looking forward to continue training
from the side congrats on the on the big
milestones and then and they really
thank you for coming here and sharing
your story oh thanks Michael I look
forward to or coughing when I get to
Israel thank you